[Musique]
je suis un peu stressé il y a deux
raisons la première c'est que je sais
que j'ai une grosse prise de sang on va
peut-être faire un petit malaise quand
même et la deuxième c'est que je dois
faire un recueil de sel problème c'est
que là j'ai pas tellement envie et j'ai
un peu l'angoisse de la la feuille
blanche quoi on te dit tous merde
littéralement allez champion ou je vais
respirer fa mais dis donc jamis comment
on ch dans un pot vous avez une petite
poche en dessous vous avez des petites é
va falloir déper et mettre en pli les C
qui va servir de support pour la cuvette
des toilettes vous enlevez le couvercle
pour pouvoir faire votre recueil vous
pouvez le poser sur la la cuvette
directement très bien une fois que c'est
fait vous refermez bien les quatre
petites aettes vous refermez après bien
les les sécurités voilà et en fait il va
falloir un petit peu là vous avez une
valve pour enlever l'air vous poussez un
petit peu la poche et ça permet
d'enlever l'air d'ord ok ça marche ça
marche ok on est d'accord que c'est un
drone le machin non voyz en tout cas
c'est pas un pot comme quand on fait une
analyse de caca classique